the Democrat view on abortion is that
when presented with a Down Syndrome baby
you know you do a little test while the
baby's in the womb and say oh your
baby's going to have Down syndrome most
Democrats want to murder that baby most
of them the question I'll give it to you
straight so you don't think I'm hiding
anything here do you strongly support
support oppose or strongly oppose
abortion because the child would be born
with Down Syndrome 56% of Dems say they
support those abortions only 42% oppose
not even close which means that most
Democrats want to genocide
people not all people with mental
retardation but actually a specific
group of people who can be extremely
high functioning who according to every
social scientific statistic
will report higher levels of happiness
certainly than Democrats